[Music]  I know what you're thinking how's the  milkshake salesman till the fast-food  empire with an annual revenue of 700  million dollars persistence please  Castle sales sorry good well a lot  interest we got an order to anyone in  particular McDonald's there for a little  tour my brother had a brilliant idea  orders ready in 30 seconds  there should be McDonald's everywhere  franchise franchise franchise how can we  be almost on the capital did you eat our  honoree negotiate my lousy deal their  camp  can't or won't ray what no you build an  empire by owning the land you're not in  the burger business you're in the real  estate business I'm gonna take the  future I want to win McDonald's can be  the new American Church there's a wolf  in the henhouse we let him in that  glorious name McDonald's I have it you  don't have it you sure about that  watching history repeats itself oh thank  you silent  I'm on